but we're to talk about The Witcher a
little bit The Witcher 3 says you guys
went to Poland's
Nobel weeks ago and you've been crafting
lovingly dare I say this video series
that like really just kind of like
investigates these different different
aspects of the the the franchise in a
way that's I think really cool form like
sort of before release coverage because
normally you can really only get that
in-depth afterwards yeah but you're also
kind of not doing a spoiler thing yeah
it's real hard to skirt that line like
we we've making three videos but they're
all like about 10-15 minutes each so
they're pretty packed full of
information but yeah the first one's
kind of just like the interesting story
about like the history of CD Projekt or
said that project as we were you were
dropping the same day yeah that's that's
all they talk referred to it as we
couldn't not call it that for him and
second one dives into a lot more about
like what the world is like we sort of
debuted the map for the first time and
which was which was which that's cool
yeah and I can't took a while for us to
figure out what the hell is going on
with the map because yes Sumerian it
looks it's not really one big world it's
it's kind of like two big worlds stuck
together and then there's a bunch of
like almost like instance little areas
that are like inside buildings that are
away from there and so the way you've
described it like you've described the
game as sort of a fantasy Red Dead
Redemption yeah feeling but Red Dead
Redemption entirely contiguous just one
map right but then they have on the
other hand at the end of last year
Dragon Age Inquisition which had large
areas but they were fast you couldn't
travel between them you have to fast
travel and some of them were just like a
city center so they're much smaller than
like the wilds that were elsewhere so it
seems like this one you know certainly
in terms of its formal structure is more
like Dragon Age but I guess what in
terms of your comparison I think when
you are going I'd say it's more like Red
Dead what it actually kind of feels like
is he already shadow of Mordor had like
one big map yeah and then you know not
really spoilers at this stage I don't
think it's a little while into it you're
like oh my god there's a whole other big
map it's kind of like that except the
map size is more the size of Red Dead
Redemption okay so it's like one big map
but like all the stuff to do and then
you want your luck this the Skellig ours
which we didn't and we were about
six hours in and that's like a whole
other one like that's five whole islands
together so it's kind of like that it's
it's definitely not as limiting as like
well you've played a lot more Dragon Age
and I have and II remember how there's a
horse and Dragon Age yes well no one
used that thing barely use that's
terrible yeah this one you have to use
the road is great but if these people
have been comparing this to like Skyrim
and saying like oh it's like this much
bigger than Skyrim and stuff but I can
scare him you [ __ ] walked everywhere
yes awesome yeah yeah I wanted to I'm
like no wonder it wasn't so big because
you're not pelting around on the horse
told I mean this like Roche you're a
horse you're with basic idiom the entire
time that's you're always running around
read dead stuff whatever people talk
about like this game world is bigger
than that game world I mean it's kind of
like interesting from a technical level
but in terms of gameplay experience I
feel like it's in the same realm as like
how many players does this multiplayer
game have yeah it the number doesn't
mean anything outside what means
something is how they balance it how the
game sort of makes you feel in that
space and if you're feeling like red
dead in these maps then I mean that yeah
that's gonna felt it's kind of hard to
judge after already playing like six
hours to read or feel like like the
variety of the questions stuff like how
engaging it'll be like hours into the
game and most of that stuff we've
covered in video three but since you're
here and is there any things like
specific you want to talk about that we
didn't cover in the videos because it's
quite a lot we we didn't kind of by
design and as other stuff we sort of
Forgotten the bad but in either what
respect is there anything like we didn't
cover do you wanna talk about well the
problem was there's some of the stuff is
kind of too complex and maybe we don't
want to cover it because it's like stuff
that's fun to figure out on your own
like the leveling system is a lot
different than the other games but I
can't for the life of me maybe so that
was just like jet lag - [ __ ] I can't
explain it other than it's like divided
into sections that unlock net level cap
so it's like one through ten you have
this many things like ten through 20 you
have it unlocks like four more skills
and then you can like put skills in and
out and then there's a mutagen slot
within those ones that like yeah if if
they're color coded so they line up to
the certain skills it gives you even a
bonus to that skill okay which I don't
know if that makes it away like
reinforcing similar skill group yeah or
just like math yeah I mean that's like
styles and
they're all over the place like I was
thinking oh the one I got was useless
because I was never gonna play that way
oh yeah you know like you can really get
your they say tend to be sort of like
you know if you want to be using the
crossbow a bunch and dodging if you want
to be using signs and weird they give
you a crossbow after the first like the
first like prologue fight which is a
this like super scripted Griffin fight
which is good for your first boss fights
or monster fight because you're just
getting used to it yeah but it's this
like scripted Griffin fight where you
fight a Griffin and then after like it's
health bar goes down half and like flies
away and you run after well your horse
and then you fight it but the crossbow
was literally useless no damage it was
only used to like get him hey calm down
maybe but I think he even did any I
think he did anyway but yeah it's funny
cuz in the books it's like explicit
about it's like they don't use
projectiles or something and they're
already in the game he like one of the
best emerge just kinda like winks and
he's like take the cross one girl it's
like what am I doing with this and he's
like no you need it there's lots of nice
of the Winx through the book that's cool
there's so many good references to the
book so you guys were at the books a
little yeah I read the first book you
read a bunch them before us to just say
I read the first one before we went to
Poland just to get the sort of deeper
flavor of it Vietnamese idlies competed
the first of which kids I haven't I
played I didn't I won and I played like
not much of two at all mhmmm I was
honored as people that found it like
really intimidating I just couldn't like
of me not it's not yeah I was I think I
was just I was impatient I think as well
yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of systems
to I mean they're sort of it's not a
it's a world that is rich but in the
witcher 2 it was sort of like that
richness
yeah you know feel like you came upon
you all at once a little bit this one it
seems like you know they're doing a
prologue they're doing an early sort of
starting area you guys talked about this
in your video that most did yesterday a
lot so I guess you know like just sort
of sort of starting out and getting into
the open world [ __ ] off love that guy
know one of the things that when you
start out an open world that you guys
both said is like once we got free I
just wanted like run as far as I could
yeah and so part of that is just the
natural exploration instinct part of it
is also like it's preview window I only
have so much time
get out after it and how do you feel I
guess in terms of like exploration
versus getting drawn back to following a
quest could you get any sense of that in
this short time yeah we're able to play
I mean one thing I have immediately
noticed was like from the first two
games
I had this mindset of like what to do
and I was like walking around the world
and I realized you know oh there's a
river there I guess they don't want me
going over there but then I realized oh
wait I can swim in this game I'm like oh
go in the river and then you go in the
river there's like all this stuff in the
river like treasures and secret yeah
you're like I don't have time to go do
this and then I was like wanting to
really see this quest through that I
picked up like randomly by going to
something like herbalist house fuchi was
like you need you know you need to craft
this potion and that's like okay what I
need to get this pose like ten drowner
things yeah you get trailers or one of
these like yeah yeah the maza kind of
hang out at wet spots like everywhere
and I was like well now I got a farm ten
drowners but like with the constraints
of being only there for yeah we like six
hours like oh I really want to see the
sequester but like I can't farm so here
in farm tend round I kept so well like
at one stage it felt like when you're
like you know level five and Warcraft
World of Warcraft because you're picking
up quest so we get into in the next
video a bit more you're picking up
quests all the time and they're leveled
so like obvious level four yeah and I
won sage I just booked it across the map
and I was like I'm gonna go into the
stand and I found this really crazy
quest which I'd like you to like go into
different parts of this forest to figure
out where this ghost was and they had
all these question marks Randy you had
to figure out where exactly was it was
like a level 33 and I was like she's on
one stage in the map by the time we
finished Bhangarh six hours I had like
the main quest all these secondary
quests which split off from the main
quest and then random ones that I picked
up and raw like level 4 a level 3 level
2 level 8 level 11 so like you're
constantly picking this stuff up it's
almost like you're gonna have to like go
back and find it and because the game
continues on after them like you're
finished playing it like I have a
feeling it's gonna be one of these games
were when people complete it they're
actually going to be able to like just
joint around in quests like for hours
afterwards and you know with the free
DLC sort of yeah it's the horse armor
I mean they've like not really clarified
exactly what kind of deal see there's
gonna be
seems there's some question yeah yeah
he's got there's the opportunity for
that certainly I I think those expansion
packs are going to basically you might
have seen on yesterday's video the the
overworld map we showed I think those
one of those the second expansion pack
is a new area I think it's like gonna
just get stuck on the map there just
open it up yeah we're all gerelds in
there
is highest level I think is 60 they said
something about a hundred to us so I we
never got confirmation but I think maybe
there's your progression and all that
stuff will keep going as long as yeah
it's good dude art so like I guess I
don't want to sort of ask the hype train
for this is rolling pretty strong and
we've you know that's something that we
juggle here right like how much hype is
sort of like we're just excited for a
new thing but how much is like this game
actually has me legit excited do you
think it's reaching fatigue point do you
think like it's coming into the station
finally it's like out in less than a
month yeah so that I think a lot so
that's like one of the main problems
with doing these is that we're gonna
make three videos about this game we did
because we were interested in it we went
out there actually when there was a
bunch of games coming out and so well
alright in that time it was like oh
here's another game that was like
blood-borne was out yeah that started
this month I was crazy for like good
releases and this is I went out there
being like sort of cautiously optimistic
as somebody who'd never dove into the
other two like you're a big fan of them
but it's on my left there I was like
this is like this is really the next few
months of my gaming sorted yeah it's
like I done I don't want to like you
can't tell after play for six hours if
it's going to keep you engaged at that
level yeah but I got that feeling like
when we left we didn't talk about it
intentionally but the first hour or
whatever of the game and we don't refer
to want to leave it for people but we're
not finished and you're sort of left out
into the prologue area for the first
time and I had one of those feelings we
went when we got on the [ __ ] you get on
Roach and you walk down the path and
like the the landscape is like if they
do it in a place that's like it looks
gorgeous of course and I felt like that
for a three moment when you leave the
vault 101 and it's like boom there you
go there it is
[ __ ] go have fun and get the city so
it feels like that so it has I think it
has all the ingredients of being a
really great game but like we can't
really tell we want to play for six
hours
time will tell yeah
[Music]